US-Präsident Donald Trump hat seine Kritik an den Medien verschärft
mit der Vergabe von Preisen für, seiner Meinung nach, falsche Berichterstattung.
Auf der Internet-Seite der republikanischen
Partei führte Trump am Mittwoch
zehn Gewinner der von ihm selbst ausgerufenen "Fake News Awards" auf.
Auf Platz eins landete die "New York Times", weil sie am Tag der Wahl Trumps erklärt habe,
dass sich die Wirtschaft niemals von dem neuen Präsidenten erholen werde.
Platz vier etwa erreichte eine Büste Martin
Luther Kings,
die doch nicht aus dem Oval Office entfernt worden sei, wie von Time berichtet.
Auf Platz elf führte Trump zudem nicht eine konkrete Geschichte auf, sondern allgemein
die Berichterstattung über angebliche Absprachen zwischen Russland und Trumps Wahlkampfteam.
Trotz allem gäbe es aber auch reichlich gute Nachrichten,
auf die das amerikanische Volk stolz sein könne, so Trump auf Twitter.